[Music]
hello and welcome to the endgame class
my name is Caleb Dendy and today I
wanted to walk you guys through
everybody's favorite opening in chess
that is the Berlin now I hear you
protesting at home this is an endgame
class not an opening class well can't
they just be the same thing sometimes
and that is exactly the case with the
classic Berlin endgame line now this is
one that is played quite often at the
top level of chess it's kind of seen as
the easiest way for black to try to
equalize against the Royal apes' and of
course that has made it very very
popular so why don't we see Maxime the
Sheila grab stake on the Berlin endgame
and now he has been trying to fight for
the win in a position that honestly has
pretty much well been agreed to just be
a draw so let's see it of course the
Berlin starts with E 4 E 5 Knight f3
knight c6 and Bishop e5 entering the ROI
now of course a six has for a long time
and the main main main line of the roar
of the pests but in this case the Berlin
comes after Knight f6 now in this case I
wanted to go over the main line which is
the endgame line there is this move d3
available to white if white does want to
avoid the endgame line once to play a
more classical roy type of position but
black has been equalizing pretty
comfortably with the move Bishop c5 here
and I won't go into all that because
this is an endgame class so castles
Knight takes e4 d 4 is the way to play
it for white rook e1 is seen to be
largely just to draw so d 496 Bishop
takes c6 d takes c6 d takes e5 and now
after Knight f5 we have Queen takes d8
and King takes d8 and this
is the classic Berlin quote-unquote
endgame of course there are still quite
a few pieces on the board to call it an
endgame but it kind of just is an end
game ends I'm more or less say that
because in this type of position yes the
king can still come under a little bit
of fire but it is still going to be an
act of fighting piece for black
especially and you know everybody just
seems to agree this is an endgame
so now MDL is kind of the player that's
you know it's it's hard to tell what
came first did nvl just start playing
the main line of the Berlin or did MBL's
line against the Berlin sort of just
become the main line because he kept
playing it and kept doing it pretty
decently with it as well so let's look
and see how he starts here there are two
really really main moves Knight c3 in h3
the move rook d1 Czech has also been
tried quite a few times even it moves
like b3 have have been played here there
are a lot of options for white in this
case but I wanted to look at age 3 which
is kind of the same as Knight c3 we kind
of transpose immediately after the main
move King e8 and King II is one of the
main options for black in the Berlin the
move King it is kind of seen as the less
ambitious try by black if black wants to
sometimes win the game generally they
don't play King e8 instead opting for
the move Bishop d7 when the king is
actually going to look to come out this
way via c8 instead of coming back to e8
but King EA is kind of the main try for
black it is the most respected way to
kind of just try to equalize the game
and now Knight c3 by MDL and we are in
very very standard territory now there
are once again quite a few options or a
black the move Bishop e6 the move Bishop
e7 I'll come to Minds but if you do play
like this you're ever so slightly giving
white what he wants move h3 was intended
to help prepare the move g4 after g4 97
white has the option to always kind of
bring this
King just up the board a little bit the
move 94 and 95 are also kind of the main
tries here forcing this Bishop back and
now it moves like King G to can follow
as well as well as it was like at four
just for example King G to see five hits
this night Knight back to f3 let's say B
five and you know even King G three here
and this is kind of a nice solid setup
for for white I don't want to get into
this too much though because due to
these g4 ideas with stuff like 94 with
with stuff like that
the main move for black has very much
become to just play the move h5 with h5
you you're kind of nipping g4 in the bud
by you know challenging that square
before board before it ever gets played
so now if you played the move g4 well
you're kind of just in for it not h6 and
this guy is very very weak if you play
the move g5 Knight f5 is great for black
now and this is just awful awful awful
stuff before white so h5 is quite common
and now white simply develops this piece
to Bishop f4 Bishop e7 is natural for
black to get developed now the move rook
81 Bishop e6 and Knight g5 is the way
that MV l has has been trying to play
for an advantage and there are 180 some
games here and the reason white can go
for this Knight g5 stuff is because
black did in fact commit to this h5 move
trying to challenge the d4 square this
is kind of the draw back to playing h5
you give your opponent the g5 square no
need to fear though in a 179 of those
180 some games the move Ric h6 comes on
the board defending this bishop on e6
now the move Knight takes c6 is playable
but this is very much nothing to worry
about for for black here this was kind
of an extra Bishop if white miraculously
in this position had a LightSquared
Bishop instead of this night I would
kind of say that white is close to
winning but there is no LightSquared
bishop on the board so the fact that
this bishop has disappeared is is less
important for black much more common
instead now are the moves g3 and rook Fe
and I'm gonna recommend the McAfee one
that MVL plays in this game Bishop b4 is
the follow-up for black trying to
pressure this night note that it is
possible to play other things but if you
play something slow like the move b6
well you do have to look out for this
Knight starting to come in starting to
try to invade and another kind of
nonchalant move and you might actually
end up in just a smidgen of trouble
sorry I won't play see 5c 5s kind of a
bad move let's say you just directly
pass you might end up in just a smidgen
of trouble after something like takes
and takes and just like g3 and this
Knight is nice and centralized moves
like Knight g5 can come at a later date
and white is just kind of happy here so
Bishop e4 is aimed at preventing this
knight from coming of a natural E for
square and now white just does actually
continue with the move g4 and after h6g
for H takes G 497 this is where MVL kind
of deviates from the most common move in
this position when grandmasters get to
this position and they kind of just want
to make a draw the move Knight takes c6
is the move you're going to see most
often rook takes c6 rookie 3 and they're
there just isn't a whole lot to play for
here but the move that mvl played in
this game is actually going to be trying
it for just a little bit more lvl plays
the very very interesting move f3
and so with f3 white is actually giving
black quite a bit this is taking some
risks to be sure so who sees what risks
are being taken what does the move f3
allow for black what can black do here
what can black do in this position does
anybody see
rook h8 not gonna be Rick h8 in this
case of course the thing that f3 does in
fact allow of course this is not
capturing the fish on e6 which does mean
the move Bishop takes c3 can be played
and has been played in all eight games
in which this position has appeared and
now with this Bishop still alive black
can actually gain upon on the a2 square
and that is what magnus carlsen tries in
this game against MVL and the fun
doesn't really end there after giving up
this a 2 pawn and they'll plays this
move Knight e4 aiming for the nice c5
Square hitting some weaknesses and after
a cage shape I dare you guys to find
White's next move this is more or less
the justification for allowing Bishop
takes c3 and Bishop takes a 2 so this is
the justification for the sacrifice see
if you can find MBL's next move here
[Music]
what can be done
move knight f6 is a check and it does
look pretty interesting but
unfortunately it is it is not gonna be
enough here and yet some people in the
chat do have it now it is in fact the
movie six rather instead east six is the
idea for white to fracture the black
structure and create some threats to
blacks perfectly safe Central King so if
you do play the move Knight of six G
takes f6 he takes f6 Bishop e6 takes
takes this would likely be enough for an
equal position but after Knight f6
captures are not always forced in chess
and King f8 might actually be just a
good move here now your knight is
attacked you have to give another check
or come back and if you do give this
check and come to c5 this is just gonna
be fine for black you got a couple
checks but not much else so the movie
six is the move to play here now Bishop
takes six of course white doesn't want
to give away too many pawns
so Bishop takes c7 is played in the game
and so you know now we just end up with
this funny-looking position here where
black is actually up a clean pawn and
white has a fractured structure so what
does white have in return for this well
white does get kind of some annoying
activity and that's why I think this is
one of the lines for a white that really
offers at least some winning chances you
know it's not just totally totally dead
white sacrifices this pawn on the on the
Queen side but you know these pieces
very centralized this King also very
centralized in these pieces a little bit
uncoordinated here just a little bit
uncoordinated the move 95 is what the
world champion went for in this game now
there is one other game in the database
here that I do want to briefly touch on
now after we go over this game and in
that game Anish Gary and Sergey kurakin
were playing Sergey played the move b5
and we'll see
that went for four Anish but in this
case 95 bishop up to e5 and King f8
defends this pawn on g7 of course Bishop
his attacks we get the Bishop out with
tempo now the natural follow-up for
whites you know the point of this East
six sacrifice was yes to gain c7 but
also to play this move at night c5
hitting two things at once
b5 is played for black and now once
again I want you guys to find the next
critical move for white here to keep the
game going to keep his chances alive the
next critical move what do you guys
think
what do you think so I'm at guess who
has the right idea here these pawns are
awful they're awful awful pawns and you
should hate them so of course the best
move in this case is going to be to play
the move c4 with c4 you're challenging
this knight on d5 and this pawn on b5
black of course is not so happy to let
you take on b5 so be it takes c4 comes
on the board and White has now
sacrificed a second pawn but in return
he has really fractured these pawns he's
gotten rid of one of his weaknesses and
he's opened up the B file as well now
the move rook b1 directly isn't actually
going to really be good enough here for
for white excuse me
largely because Ric h6 is starting to
activate and if you go even further play
move like it could be seven you're not
actually attaining anything move Bishop
c8 very quickly ejects this rook and
suddenly there are no safe squares for
this earth to go to you have to go
either to b8 and trade or back to B 2 or
B 1 so not really what you're looking
for
but you do create more weaknesses for
your opponent in the game and video
plays the move rook d4 and this one is
is a pretty good one challenging this
pawn on c4 now the move rook e8 is the
world champions try trying to challenge
this rook on the open e file rook takes
c4 tree gains one of the ponds for mvl
of course black really couldn't hold on
to all of these weak pawns at the same
time if you do play a move like Knight
b6 trying to defend well now maybe is
the time to take here and all of a
sudden you know you start getting a
little bit nervous with with black here
these rooks can very very quickly invade
into the position if you don't play it
with extreme caution here and that's
once again why I think MBL's take on the
Berlin is one of the best so Magnus
sacrifices this pawn back with the move
rook e8 rook takes c4 comes on the board
and now rook back up to h6 is Magnus's
he's just desperately trying to get
these rooks back into the game so that
he can challenge White's claim to all
this activity now the very very natural
move by MVL you want to step out of this
threat and you want to attack blacks
weaknesses so the move irrigate for
comes on the board
and now magnus carlsen rather than kind
of stubbornly try to hold on to these
pawns at all costs plays the move King
g8 and now after Erik takes a 7 material
is even but the position is not even in
my opinion I think in this case Magnus
has played pretty good defense so far
getting the piece is active not being
too greedy with the material but I do
think that white does have a little bit
of an edge in this position now of
course it's not much but you're playing
against the Berlin so it's really
difficult to ask for much but MVL has
somehow outmaneuvered his opponent he
has slightly more activity with his
pieces and now all of the pawns that
Magnus had as compensation have fallen
off the board the move Bishop c8 is what
Magnus tried in order to once again
begin challenging this bishop here and
this rook on e 1 and now I think MBL
plays a move that really does allow
Magnus to more or less totally equalized
in this position I think the move that
had to be played to play it for any kind
of an advantage is the move King F 2 and
the reason I think this is really the
only way to play for an edge is because
this move is aimed at actually playing
against this rook on age 6 circle age 6
has a difficult time of getting back
into play from this Square now blacks
last move of bishop see it was Bishop c8
and the idea of this move was to
continue now with f6 the point being you
want to trade off these rooks but now of
course the downside to this is that this
work cannot get back into the game using
this sixth rank there are checks but
these checks don't really get you
anywhere either if you start playing
things like a rook f1 well you've
only strayed a little bit too far away
and this Bishop is is going to come
under some fire so in this line the
movement rugged shape is actually
necessary for black to play to guard
this eighth rank and after okay Jade you
know now White has some extra time to
continue playing against the pieces with
this rook being so far out of play for
the moment in fact I move like c4 is
also well worth considering when Knight
takes c7 I think is simply just going to
be lost this Bishop cannot legally move
and it's going to be really tough to
play this position for black this pawn
is is going to fall just one example of
course other moves are playable here
like 93 hitting this pawn so maybe c4
isn't even the best King need to could
be good but okay I think King up to
would have given em BL that little bit
of an edge that he was still playing for
instead Bishop g3 was his choice and I
do think this lets black off just a
little bit easy rook takes a one Bishop
takes II one and now of course what is
the improvement for black in this line
over the previous line how is this
better for black than what we just
looked at what extra option does they
have available
and then there's a question about Bishop
d6 check I'll come back to that first
you guys answer my question
so yeah you guys see the idea rook d6
gets this jerk to a much more central
location and now black is just quite
comfortably holding on to this position
let's back up though after c4 b takes c4
why not play Bishop d6 check Bishop d6
check is a playable move and then we can
continue by taking this pawn here and
you do get this Bishop versus night and
the game the problem is due to some
awkwardness in the white pieces
you can't immediately generate any
threats against this King King f7 is a
really nice kind of important move for
white if you double up here when our
rook e8 not rook f8 rook e8 and
immediately you know pieces start coming
off the board and white is still going
to be down upon here so rather than go
for those immediate simplifications we
did see this rook d4 move instead trying
to keep a few more pieces on the board
trying to keep more chances alive okay
so then we ended up here bishop g3 and
after rook d6 I think the game was was
well in hand before the world champion
Bishop a5 was played trying to guard the
d8 square but now Magnus comes up with
this nice move Bishop takes g4 and after
Bishop takes g4 white of course is up a
piece but it's not going to be enough
with the number of pawns on the fort
black also of course did not really have
to go for this this pawn still being on
f7 means that this bishop can
comfortably move to the e6 square but it
was just kind of a matter of preference
for Magnus he saw this concrete way to
kind of end the game F takes rook g6
king f2 rook takes g4 is the point no
real way to defend that G pawn for white
and then from here rook c4 is also a
nice idea by black to pick up this final
pawn okay it check page 797 and now with
all the pawns off the board the absolute
best that white could hope for is rook
and Bishop against riff but you're never
really going to get to that endgame
these pawns are connected and totally
safe and they played on for quite a
little bit but this was not enough for
MBL to create any more winning chances
in this game the C pawn fell pretty
easily but now after a trade
it was nights in rook against rook with
this extra pawn it is a dead and draw
rook h1 check played and that is the
repetition and the game is a dead drop
so this was kind of the main main
variation of the Berlin and somehow
someway nvl did manage to generate some
chances against the world champion of
course in this case it wasn't enough but
really clever ideas to focus on there
and I do want to come back for just a
second
and review those key ideas that got him
to this position so here Knight takes c6
is by far the main move but f3 is MBL's
choice
to keep more pieces on the board and go
for these interesting and balances in
the endgame 94 and then e 6 to follow
and with these pawn sacrifices one more
critical move c4 here and now I think
white is just comfortably better it's
easier to play this position with white
in my opinion you know the move rook d4
is nice and it's difficult to find ways
to get the black pieces into the game
that being said there is one game I know
we're focusing on MVL here there is one
game in this line that I didn't want to
show you guys it is nice Gary's game and
I want to show you how this thing can
kind of go wrong so I'm gonna speed
through the opening here it's just the
main line Berlin's stuff that we were
looking at rook ad 195 as we've seen
rook h6 this is the same position we saw
rook e1 Bishop before g4 takes takes 97
and here he did try MBL's move f3 in
this game though after Bishop takes c3
takes Bishop a2 same position 94 Rock
h8e 6 same position take stakes here of
course rather than 95 as Magnus played
Sergei tried b5 now Bishop e5 rook g8
night see 595 this is all still
perfectly fine for whites and then Geary
played the very very strange move f4
which simply loses the game I don't know
why you would play this move of course
I'm sure everybody at home sees the idea
here for white of course you need to
play C for once again and then he could
have gotten very very similar counter
play to what we just saw in the previous
game but notably things can go wrong for
white here but f4 is is quite a crazy
mess I don't know how this actually
happened in Gary's mind so that's the
other game to make it this far - to this
position but unfortunately we didn't get
to see much of a game there because Gary
blundered in a jeep on which is just of
course not so good all right with that
in mind let's move on to the next main
game I want to look at this is one
between Maxime of a Shilla Grove and
Veselin Topalov in this game Topalov
went for the kind of other main plan in
the Berlin so I wanted to introduce this
one to you guys see how Maxime plays
against this one see if he can once
again manage to generate some winning
chances so of course we start with the
Berlin d4 we go for the endgame line
it's what we're analyzing h3 is MBL's
choice and now rather than the king he
ate stuff that we were looking at in the
previous games here Topalov goes for the
move Bishop d7 and this is a slightly
different way of playing it even if it's
not immediately apparent why it's going
to be different with Bishop d7 black is
not developed not developing the bishop
excuse me - perhaps the most active
square on e6 pressuring the Queen side
but he is vague hitting the square on d7
for the king
so rather than king e8 in this game
expect to see topple off try to go the
other way with the King over to c8 rook
d1 is the main move here for white
pressuring this Bishop Bishop e7 is
perfectly natural for black getting
developed and now once again we see
white go for this idea with
g4 note the move h5 is very much not
really seen here because in this
variation without the King on e8 you do
have to be very very wary of Knight g5
ideas and all of a sudden things could
go go quite quite wrong for you if
you're not careful so that's why Bishop
e7 is nice guarding this square on g5
now if 9 g5 new move Bishop takes g5
would be perfectly playable and you
can't even get away with King e8 here
because after new Knight takes f7 King
takes f7 Rick takes d7 this is no longer
coming with check and you can get quite
active quite fast so just some opening
nuances there for you Bishop e7 not h5
in this line despite h5 being the main
move in the previous line and once again
MVL goes for the direct g4 night h4 we
see these minutes come off the board and
now 92 and this is still pretty mainline
stuff here so 92 King c8 Knight up to F
3 hits this Bishop Bishop back to e7
and now MVL plays the move Bishop g5
trying to trade off this guy for this
guy and while this isn't the worst idea
for black to even take of course you're
going to run into some real problems on
this f7 square if you're not careful so
the five times this has been reached
over the board the move Bishop c5 was
was played and now from here MBL
continues playing quite naturally just
and develops the stroke ripped up to d3
b6 now for black is sensible giving this
King another square able to bring this
rook into play and also you know just
just supporting the c5 square if we ever
want to play c5 in in Bishop c6 so
Bishop e3 now for white we see Bishop
takes III rook takes c3 and h6 now we
have this position in the endgame where
it is the classic Berlin structure there
are there's only one minor piece left on
the board though
that is this night versus this bishop
and so we'll see which minor piece ends
up being better here first the move
ripped d1 and c5 is played and then I'd
like you guys to try to come up with a
maneuver for white to really improve his
peace his minor piece the knight
specifically and put a lot of pressure
on black it can become very very easy
for black to go wrong here
yes sir went over this in his Berlin
video well yes sir has good taste
[Music]
drink some water bro I've got a sprite
here
good call though good call them you move
east six has been suggested moves 92 to
see four have been suggested I don't
really think the c-4 square is much and
a much of an improvement for the night
in this case just for example let's say
some nothing move even if you do get
night c4 these squares are all very
easily defended by the black pawns and
this Knight isn't doing much over here
the move east six isn't quite right in
this particular position because we
can't just take with the bishop but this
e six threat is one of the critical
ideas for white in this position you
know the threat of playing east six is
always kind of looming and then yet it
looks like some people have it now the
move of course is night h4 aiming for
this at five square now at first glance
when I saw the move Knight age four I
was like well okay I mean you can play
Knight age four but it doesn't really
seem to do a lot I'm just going to play
the move g6 and now the f5 squares is
mine and what is your night doing on h4
actually I'm not so sure I would like to
ask you sir what is your night doing and
then you know at first glance I was like
yeah and I just follow up with Bishop e6
player ta get my King out of the way and
life is good but of course white does
have a very direct move here that is
good for him and I think some of you
guys probably have some idea of what
that move is already of course who I'm
talking about is this key idea that was
mentioned on the previous turn it's East
six here ye six is the idea for white to
try and play for an edge here if Bishop
takes six well now the nice sacrifice
Knight takes c6 comes on the board and
this Bishop is a little bit loose on e6
are the zombies attacking upstairs who
knows Jim who knows what they're doing
up there but it is kind of terrifying
sounding anyways so g6 cannot be played
which is why Topalov went for the Move
g5 in this case just hitting this knight
directly and saying well okay if you're
going to f5 you're not going to be
looking at my pawn on g7 I've already
dealt with that and you have no way back
through the age for square so Knight a5
was played and now we get this
interesting position and unfortunately
for Topalov here he did kind of just
blunder into a significantly worse
endgame that's a MBL managed to go on to
win but the position is actually very
very interesting still it's difficult to
pinpoint if black has really done much
wrong here so far black has just done
very very natural moves some pieces were
traded off the board but now all of a
sudden with this knight on f5 it perhaps
white has a little bit of an advantage I
think the best move in this position is
actually to play the move Bishop e6 note
that if you come out the other way to b5
for example you're kind of running the
risk of a six
the board and this might just kind of
run over your entire position for
example take stakes play move like king
b7 all of a sudden the h6 pawn is is
already hanging for example takes take
sticks and now Knight f7 and you don't
really regain this pawn quite so easily
so I think the best move is to play
Bishop e6 preventing this e six break
but now the move Knight g7 is available
to white and this is starting to break
down the blockade just a little bit I
think really the the only main move here
has to be rook d8 trying to go for a
little bit of a simpler endgame and
after rook takes d8 and more pieces come
off the board for example to move rook
f3 and rook f6 and this this endgame
might be holding it probably is holding
but it is going to be very very
uncomfortable for black to deal with
there's really two things you can do
here you can either come to d8 or or a
chain
is the more active try h8 is kind of the
try that says I'm just gonna defend my
pawn and what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do about it nothing I hope
but now white does have a way to to
break through here if you guys want to
try to find at home go ahead I'm just
going to show it it is this move f4 the
move f4 and now after G takes up for the
King comes up the board and white will
be able to create a passed pawn and play
for a win now if you do play the move d8
here going for activity this might be a
better try for example route takes h6
rook D to Ric h7 is check King eh note
if you play King d8 then the move f4 is
actually very very strong creating a
passed pawn immediately
so King 8 is a little bit better keeping
an eye on this King side a little bit
more keeping this King closer to this
passed pawn so can eat for example Rick
takes e7 rook takes c2 and now even
moves like like b4 and I am not entirely
certain what's going on in this endgame
but it does kind of start to feel like
White is the one playing for an edge
with this three versus one going on over
here so I think maybe this endgame is
something that's a that y can actually
try in and play for an advantage there
are other ideas like playing an earlier
age for that are conceivable there are
also you know you can't really play a
move like King f1 just trying to guard
because this trick is going to get
active anyways whether whether you like
it or not so I think Bishop e6 was a
much better try for Topalov instead
though he plays the move Bishop takes f5
and now after G takes f five black is is
really in for a struggle in in this
position this is going to be a little
bit of a struggle for black
yes says the classes knew the class has
been around a little bit now ponds but
it feels like it's brand-new okay so now
after G takes f five we do have this
opportunity to always create a passed
pawn and without the minor pieces on the
board
unless black can get the rooks active
very very early on white has a huge head
start with both these rooks on great
squares threatening to invade if you go
for a similar line that we just looked
at with a move like Earth d8 well you
can take this and then white can simply
sit on the position and that is kind of
the difference here in that previous
position it wasn't so easy to just kind
of sit and do nothing because the rook
came to e5 or d5 or d2 and created
immediate threats but now our King just
has a road of entry and our rook can
very adequately guard all of our
weaknesses from a square like d2 just
for example if rook d8 here the move
rook d3 is potentially playable the move
rookie - I think is also potentially
playable but you might want to look out
for this move rook d4 so maybe even
Europe d3 here when I'm pretty sure you
can't go in for the King and pawn on
games and that would be very very
difficult for black so instead Topalov
tries to keep both rooks on the board
and play for counter play this way but
now the same idea by white simply King
g2 you get this king active and it's
gonna be tough to hold on rook da truck
takes da tour at 68 and we do get kind
of a version of what we just saw and now
King f3 white is just threatening to
invade directly C fort was topal ops try
trying to get these pawns a little bit
further up the board so they can become
more relevant but now rook
efore b5 defends the pawn but simply
King g4 at this point and this is dead
with the dual threats of be six in the
Queen and King h5 coming like doesn't
have time to come down the board because
this pawn is far too strong and this is
just simply lost now for Topalov King f5
e 7
6 and after kingi 6 Veselin simply
resigns and it's kind of a funny
position to resign at first glance you
know it looks like the king is
blockading maybe black can add can play
on for a little bit but the the simple
fact of the matter is that the guru khan
h8 is trapped so that rook is going to
die in the next few moves you play
anything King g7 in the rugged Ice King
here King g7 King f7 and the rook the
rook dies unfortunate unfortunate for
topalov so this was a big win by MDL in
the Berlin endgame and this idea of
Knight h ford f5 proves to be a little
bit problematic for for black in this
specific line now I do think the move
Bishop e6 very much might be holding
with this idea of rook d8 but it's
certainly not easy to to play as black
you know you see this for coming on f6
and it does look quite terrifying and it
does look kind of just optically very
very strong for white so where could
black have improved of course the
specifics that v move was a huge mistake
here perhaps even the move Bishop e7
would have been a a simpler try I think
the pure Night vs Bishop endgame is
something that's slightly advantageous
to to white of course at this point y
can still play on you know he's getting
activity on this file but I do like
keeping this Bishop around for black I
think just for a little bit longer at
least ok
the pieces are home they're starting
squares in the final position yet that's
that's the nice note alright I have one
more
verlan endgame to show you guys after
that one so we've seen kind of two of
the main plans by black so far now why
don't we take a look at a game mvl had
against the one and only David Howell
David Howe one of the top English
players been in and out of the 2700 for
quite some time now so this game like
all the other games starts with E 4 and
goes directly into the Berlin
take stakes h3 first is the move or dirt
Chozen by MVL now 97 is played in this
game and this one is slightly
non-standard I must be honest with you
97 not the most common planet by any
stretch much more common are these fish
57 or King EA positions but 97 instead
is David house try here
rook d1 is a Czech king e8 out of Czech
now Knight c3 and the idea for black
with this move 97 is kind of I was gonna
say two-fold but but really multifold it
steps out of g4 first of all this was a
very very common idea for white that we
were looking at to gain some space on
the Kings side hitting this Knight it
also challenges this epon with this next
move Knight g6 this is the main square
that black wanted to put this knight on
challenging this pawn and now there are
a variety of moves here for white the
move b3 is perhaps the most common the
idea being Bishop e7 and this Knight can
come back to e 2 and this Bishop can
come out to F or to be two there's also
the idea of just Bishop e3 there's
nettie to here directly
there's even it moves like Bishop c5
rook e1 in the game mvl plays the move
Knight to d4 and this is slightly less
common than those other moves that I
listed and the reason for that is it's
pretty apparent this pawn is undefended
and so you can't in fact actually
capture this pawn if you so desire the
reason white sacrifices it here is
because he wants to go for Bishop f4 and
challenging this C pawn as we saw with
this e 6 move in a earlier put in
earlier position so now I have 6 would
come on the board likely and the move
Bishop takes e5 f takes e5 has been
played a couple times for example Knight
f3 56 Knight takes e5 is regaining the
pun you don't really want to take this
guy because
the spin giving up the bishop pair and
now after Bishop f5 rook d2 is the most
common move and this has been played a
couple of times both of those times to
to a draw and so this Knight takes e5
move is perhaps blacks best chance at
playing for a draw here but David Hal
chose instead to play Bishop d7 opting
for more pure just Berlin and game type
positions where this pawn on e5 does
remain now though the problem for black
is white isn't going to give you a
second chance to capture this pawn on e5
of course now the moved f4 comes on the
board and this is how MBL is playing for
an advantage here rook d8 is black's
idea getting this rugged directly into
the game and now simply Bishop e3 is
developing h5 on the board for black
still wanting to keep an eye on the g4
square and now let's simple the easy
rook d2 and white it just doubles on the
D file Atkin Bishop e7 now this position
as with many present positions in the
Berlin is not a huge edge for white but
I do feel once again and that it is
easier to play for white white can
create problems for black and black is
going to have to work slightly harder
and then white to solve those problems
in the game David how it shows a six and
now after the move Knight e4 you just
see optically that White's pieces do
look very well placed in the center
while the black bishops look a little
bit compressed on e7 and d7 now 9h fort
was played in the game and I do think
that this move was in fact a little bit
of a little bit of a mistake here it
does just allow this move Bishop F to
which hits this night and now this
Knight really doesn't have anything
better to do then come back to g6 this
was probably an attempt by David Hale to
get a quick repetition you know want to
see ok MBL went in for this Berlin
endgame one can we just like wash our
hands be done with this game but
unfortunately MVL wanted to play
here now Bishop g3 comes on the board I
mean after h4 bishop h2 this bishop has
perhaps slightly been improved
supporting these pawns from behind
instead of guarding in this empty
diagonal now the move c5 comes on the
board for black this is a very very
common move by black giving this bishop
a little bit more scope and taking away
the d4 square from the white knights
Knight f3 comes on the board and Knight
back to f8 is another slightly strange
looking move and MBL just plays these
positions very very simply King f2
getting the King into the game now rook
age 5 comes on the board for black once
again with this King on e8 it's
difficult to get the rook into the game
on this back row so you'll see black
play for activity with moves like rook
age 5 or Ric age 6 now Knight c3 is the
big reroute in this game for MDL once
this pawn moves from c6 to c5 very often
the downside is it does give up control
of the d5 square and that's exactly what
Knight c3 is aimed at taking advantage
of the move Bishop f5 was played and now
Knight d5 is the natural follow-up for
mvl 96 comes on the board defending the
c7 pawn and now c-4 by white and this is
how games in the Berlin are sometimes
you know rarely of course but sometimes
end up being decisive both players have
kind of made an effort to keep a few
more pieces on the board here and as
such there is a lot more room for air in
this case David Howell makes a good move
b5 challenging blacks or challenging
White's claim to the c-4 to the c4 and
indirectly the d5 square and um you'll
kind of buckles under this and does just
take off this light squared Bishop on e7
riff takes d2 is inserted or takes d2
King takes e7 and now C takes b5 a takes
B 5 and MBL is
picking against hope for an outside past
upon on the a file and some type of way
to play on with this now King III is the
very principled and game moved by MDL
getting the king further into the center
in g5 to follow now Knight takes d5
Knight takes d5 f takes d5 rook takes g5
and King f4 hits both pieces but Rick h5
saves both pieces now rook d5 comes on
the board hitting some of these Queen
side weaknesses c6 is nice by black now
rook takes c5 King d7 and this is not
gonna lie to you guys a totally equal
endgame here this one is pretty much
just just dead equal so I wanted to
pause here for a moment
looks like we've still got plenty of
time I was kind of rushing there but we
do have time here it to pause and I want
to ask you guys if your name is Maxine
but Sheila graph here what are you doing
to play on for a win in this position
which pawns are looking to target and
which threats are you hoping to make not
necessarily against pawns but could be
any any kind of threat what threats are
you trying to make here how do you pose
problems to your opponent my question to
you
so chess King has one idea
Bishop g1 to f2 is one idea so these are
some pretty good ideas
use the e pawn bishop g'wan bishop F to
target the backward pawn on c6 so as
always and end games like these even an
end games where you're not necessarily
better any games where it's more natural
for you to play the way to press on is
to try and stretch the opponent's pieces
just a little bit thin you want to look
to create threats on both sides of the
board so I really do think this idea
with Bishop g1 to f2 isn't the worst
idea ever created because you're trying
to create threats on this Kings side as
well as on the c6 pawn on the Queen side
mdl chose to first include this b3 move
and this is the other idea that you guys
mentioned in the chat you want to always
be hinting that you're going to play the
move a4 now I don't recommend that you
play the move a4 it directly like right
away
the idea is potentially a later a 4 but
it's another one of those cases where
the threat is sometimes stronger and
then execution so by playing b3 and not
playing a 4
you're kind of leaving it up to your
opponent to be calculating a4 on every
turn making sure a 4 on every turn is
not good enough to win the game
so b3 is a great start and now after
Bishop back to e6 the move rook c2 was
kind of required to card in the second
rank against any rook shenanigans here
Rick f5 check did come on the board and
now King III rook g5 and Bishop f4 is
nice to hit the rook and rook back to
the g6 square and so white hasn't made a
ton of progress here just yet
but he is beginning to organize his
pieces to guard all of his weaknesses
and still create threats against the
opponent of course the c6 phone is still
challenged the a4 threat still exists
luckily for black though he has kind of
solved this problem of the h4 pawn so
here the move king F 2 was MBL's choice
over protecting this pawn and hinting
that potentially one day he's gonna play
move like g4 or g3 David Hal aimed to
simplify
immediately move f6e takes f6 rook takes
f6 was played Rick d2 is a Czech king g7
and now see if you can find the move
that MVL found in order to play this
position for an advantage it's time to
put on your tactical hats put on your
tactic hats see if you can find
something
put on your tactic hats
rook d6 hangs all of your remaining
pieces I don't recommend it Bishop g5 is
illegal unfortunately mr. g5 would be a
fantastic move if only it were legal so
some people have found the correct first
move but in order to play the correct
first move you do need to see a pretty
counterintuitive tactical line so I
challenge you guys to come up with that
tactical line those of you who are
giving just one move here
so okay the move King III I'm move King
III is perfectly fun I'm not gonna tell
you that move that King III is a bad
move but it is not really changing the
position meaningfully your opponent's
just gonna play York g6 and you're back
to more of the same here you're back to
more the same maybe your King can can
start coming up even further but you do
have to to realize that like this is
starting to even turn against you with
your King being so far away so not King
III now what I'm looking for here
okay if I can make two moves in a row
kingi through Bishop g5 would be great
but after King III Black's gonna play
rook g6 so the move that is correct
the first move that some people have
said is in fact going to be the move
g3 I think this is the best way for for
white to try to win here and with you
know perfect hindsight white didn't end
up winning so of course it was the best
try other moves I mean these are like
playable moves but like why would you
want to do this to yourself even you
you're not really playing for a win here
you're just trying to find creative ways
to not play King III but the move g3 is
is quite nice the point being you're
daring your opponent to kind of you know
go for some of this and you're
attempting to use the immediate
configuration of the pieces to create a
passed pawn here on the on the King side
for example if the move Bishop to d5
comes on the board well now we can play
the move King g1 and we are in fact
going to end up with a passed pawn over
here now I'm not saying that's always
gonna be enough to win but a passed pawn
is a passed pawn and it's much better
than what white had initially now that
tactical line that I said you guys must
be able to see is actually the one after
Bishop takes h3 and this was played in
the game there's really only one way
here for a white to keep winning chances
alive otherwise you just kind of lost
your extra pawn on h3 so if you guys
want to find it go ahead pause now try
and find out I'm just gonna show it the
move here is G takes h4 believe it or
not hanging this bishop with check rook
takes that floor check King g3 and now
these two pieces are both attacked and
it is difficult to defend them in fact I
dare say impossible
so rook f1 was played in the game in
fact Rick f8 was a little bit better
perhaps to try and defend you can get at
this a pawn immediately and also keep in
front of
pawn here but now after King takes h3 c5
is David Hales try rook c2 is
challenging these pawns King d6 and now
this pawn starts to run King d5 and now
white to move and win weight to move and
win there's only one winning move in
this position let's see if you guys can
find it
and floor has been suggested I get the
feeling and for was suggested because I
accidentally hovered over this which
makes a blue arrow showing a for but I
fooled you
once again a for is not the move they'll
show you everybody thing say for ah
stupid Caleb showed the move not this
time not this time okay so in fact some
people do have it the move h6 here looks
to be the most natural but this is in
fact going to be a pretty big mistake
here you've put too much distance
between the pawn and your king and after
the move rook f6 this pawn is actually
indefensible h7 means rook h6 so the
move that is required in the move that
does win is this move rook h2 now of
course the rook supports the pawn from
behind and we can push this pawn as far
as we want able to step our King out of
the way whenever necessary
if black went for a blockade here you
would simply play age six rook age seven
and now this King is going to be in time
to be pretty nasty and if this King
comes back to defend the rook this rook
just steps over to the Queen side and
starts cleaning up in the game black did
not go for this type of blockade instead
opting to just push c4 trying to make
his own Queen before a white Queens but
of course it is just not going to work
out here for him age six
mvl ignores the C pawn c3h7 rook f8 now
and now King g4 is making a threat rook
h8 was played in the game now King f5 is
a nice little accuracy one small note
about King and pawn and games is there
are many different paths to from one
square to the next that take the same
number of moves for example the most
direct seems to be king g5 king g6 King
g7 but that takes three moves and you
don't lose any time by going to f5 first
and it is nice to shoulder this king out
of the way however however and
has actually blundered a small bit here
it was possible now for David how to
draw this position with accurate play he
starts with the move king d4 which is
fine King g6 now and there is I believe
one move here that draws the game for
black one move to draw the game
everyone is congratulating me on my
trick do you want to see me do it again
what what what was that the right move
what oh is that the right move oh well
is that is that the right move nobody
knows nobody knows King b3 only moved
King D through King D through King to
three rook takes h7 so you don't want to
play rook takes h7 until you are
absolutely forced to until you are
absolutely forced to otherwise you're
just giving your opponent extra time
still understand why he didn't pin the
rook with the bishop when he had the
chance
sorry I never showed it on the board
that's because I couldn't show it on the
board it was literally illegal to pin
the bishop the bishop was pinned or to
pin the Brooke the bishop itself was
pinned to the king so of course it is
this move b4 and the point here is
that's the King and pawn endgame that
ensues is actually going to be going to
be drawn so King g7 forces this pawn off
the board King takes a page 7 and after
king d3 c2 c1 this rook has to trade
itself for this guy and with b4 on the
board the white king simply isn't in
time now okay I guess I can show this
really quick so King d3 just for example
King g6 c2 and I've managed to actually
lose this now for for white which is
impressive to say the least so clearly
you don't want this pawn on b4 because
you get trebuchet and might loose so
white in this case would actually have
to start giving some checks with with
this stuff and this would be the draw
but okay in the game David how play the
move king d3 so now what is the way to
win the game what is the way to win the
game with with white here
the cleanest way to win the game
b44 white is what is being suggested
so b4 actually doesn't get the job done
here because you're just losing too much
time c2 is going to be played and you're
gonna run into some similar situations
here so yet you guys haven't now the
move is a four you just create another
passed pawn and now of course the King
and pawn n games are all going to be
losing because this guy is behind that
guy and that is exactly what happened in
the game rook aah a queen and then David
Howell had to go in for the losing Queen
versus rook end game which MVL just
finessed out of his mind
easiest win of his life right easiest
one of his life never in depth yeah you
just do this and then check and then
yeah the the Zug and then the more check
and then and then this guy this guy
drops so pretty nice win there from MVL
in this berlin and game once again for
those curious the move that blunders the
wind here is actually going for this age
six move immediately much better is to
take on c4 and after b takes c4 of
course you always have this option to
play the move a4 whenever you need to
create this past pawn and now you can
just push this pawn to victory rook have
8 inch 7 h8 king g4 and there's no way
to be fast enough here with with black
this pawn is always going to run so that
is more or less MV else take on the
various plans for black in the Berlin
endgame of course you know with great
perfect play black can draw the game of
chess that's just how it works
but MVL is really the player I would
turn to in the Berlin and game for
interesting ideas in ways to create
practical problems for black hopefully
this has given you all some ideas to go
home and try against your you know least
favorite sparring partner who always
plays the Berlin and game against you
ruins Roy Lopez's hopefully you can
score a few wins using these clever
ideas
MBL that's all from us tonight on the
YouTube channel here thank you so much
for joining me if you're watching live
be sure to head over to the twitch
channel for another episode of analyze
your games if you're watching the video
that is it for tonight my name is Caleb
gunby and thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you